[Music]
let's go out to Hartford Connecticut and
talk to the almighty Nick what's up Nick
hello Dr deloney what
up not much how about you rocking on to
the Breaking Dawn my brother what about
you that's great I consider myself
fortunate to be speaking to such an
experienced and knowledgeable person
such as yourself and I just wanted to
stay I'm starting your book I'm looking
forward to embracing its lessons and
thank you for your hard work well thank
you dude appreciate you how can I help
man let's see how do I move forward
after a turbulent romantic relationship
how do I recover when I feel so
unattractive in dating and how do I give
in dating when I felt like that's all I
do and if I can give you a little bit of
context yeah go for it uh on p on paper
I'm successful I have money saved I have
good safe home healthy supportive family
and friends including two married
Brothers with three kids each I have a
good paying unit job and I volunteer in
the community I work out and I eat
healthy so I have a positive Roman I've
had positive romantic relationships but
the last few were unhealthy without
using the label of borderline I had a
girlfriend of about 9 months who
exhibited all the DSM symptoms of
borderline then my most recent
relationship I um of about 10 months
ended in June and was extremely
turbulent she's diagnosed bipolar 1 type
1 and around June stated she was very
sorry as she was Rapid Cycling she was
manipulative abusive and became a
heavier
Drinker as you've mentioned in the show
before I felt so utilitarian and she
consumed all my energy and then since
June she claimed I abused her is suing
me in small claims court and she's been
doing almost anything she can to make my
post Rel relationship life difficult and
everyone in my family is seeing this
unhealthy and perilous result as this
could impact my job and overall I just
feel beat up I felt like my love and
giving nature were exploited I feel like
this extra challenge in trusting woman
again and even some ways trusting myself
and I feel so isolated unfulfilled and
partially because I think she's behind
me getting Bann from a dating website to
move forward and I'm not thriving after
all this and I just feel like I'm
alone yeah man you got you got your
heart broken and you got
burned yeah like um you're not crazy
man oh thank you I uh
have you ever done martial arts or
anything no okay I remember the first
time this awesome guy named sonado
knocked me
out he uh was a great boxer and he just
smoked me just melted me with a shot
with a with a punch and I slumped over
up against the wall in our gym and I
crashed to the floor and I got up and it
was quick and I had a bad headache and I
was kind of just wobbly somebody took me
home and the next day I was out I don't
ever want to do this again this sucks
this is the worst this is
awful and then about two no about a week
later I went back just to
watch I ended up doing a few
drills the next day I was back on the
mats doing Jiu-Jitsu stuff you see what
I'm
saying I got smoked
man I needed a
break you got smoked you got hurt yeah
and it sounds like the best parts of you
the guy who you are sounds like you're a
giving guy sounds like you're a guy who
works really hard sounds like you're a
guy who does his best to love people in
his community and his
Circle and there's something super
unsettling when somebody takes that love
and compassion and weaponizes it against
you exactly yeah you can check in on
something somebody like hey are you okay
are you okay and then they say he's
harassing
me or you go pick somebody up who's had
too much to drink and they say you know
he picked me up or what whatever the
thing is and you're just sitting there
going what
right I would think if you were ready to
jump back into a dating
relationship that if I was your friend I
would tell you please don't do that
please take some time to
heal mhm okay you see what I'm saying
let me ask you a hard question you gave
me a whole bunch of really impressive
external
metrics do you like
Nick I I like me I think I have good
value I just I think usually in romantic
relationships it just it doesn't show
through especially at the start why not
so why
not um cuz it sounds like you're a guy
that's doing a whole lot of exhausting
performing to make sure that you present
the right
way and I just like
Nick
um yeah I I believe that other people
may have more I don't know exciting
lives or something like that um
why
why what makes you
unexciting
I I I feel like some of it comes from
just I don't even though I do all this I
feel like I lack confidence yeah so it
doesn't really come through to people
and so when I bring anything I do have
that's uh of value and kind of
spontaneous or exciting it just I don't
know I feel like that's not something
that's really um attractive at the
moment or attractive to a date or
something I don't know yeah I think
that's a story you're telling yourself
brother because the way you introduced
yourself to me is not dude I'm an
awesome younger brother of Two Awesome
Brothers I'm a member of my community uh
you introduced me yourself to me by a
bunch of stuff you have and a bunch of
stuff you've done you handed me a resume
of
you yeah and I don't when I used to hire
people the resume got you in the door I
didn't care about the resume when you
got in there I want to know
you and you're walking around with a
story saying I'm uninteresting and so
the only way I can be of any sort of
value in a relationship is to let people
know I make good money I got a nice car
I've got a nice house I'm
safe and my brothers are happily
married and if you were going to date my
daughter I would tell her to run from
you because that is a guy who is coming
in so guarded up that it's going to take
a long time to get to know you and I
mean this with all due
respect the only people who are going to
be attracted to all these external
metrics are people who are grasping at
their own
straws see what I'm saying yeah and
you're gonna create this dance over and
over and over again because if you want
if you walked into a group of people
that I hang out with a group of women
that I hang out with and we're like hi
my name is Nick I have a great job I
have a great car I have a nice safe
house they'd be like all right dude I'm
out if you walk into a group of
people who are struggling for any sort
of security at
all they're going to latch on to
that but if you walked into a room
confident because you have a nice home
and you got a good job it might be
boring a lot of us have boring jobs you
know what I mean my job looks un boring
but most of my day is spent in meetings
and reading nerdy Journal articles right
and trying to like write a talk very
little of my day is actually in front of
a a microphone or on a stage and so all
of us have boring jobs boring parts of
our
job it's knowing no I put the work in
man I'm a catch I'm freaking Nick I'm a
catch hey what's up my name is Nick I
like punk rock music what about
you but you can only get there if you
like
Nick
okay what are you what are you into what
do you
like um I love going to museums I'm
actually I graduated U with a degree in
art so I like art um I like rock indoor
rock climbing these days so I like to be
active I like like being outside
bicycling what kind of art do you
like uh painting
Landscapes who in the world told you
that's
boring
uh I don't know where that came from
it's absolutely Stone
nonsense you have an art degree and you
have a good job both of those things
yeah that makes you a unicorn
Nick you know I mean most of my friends
with art
degrees don't have stable homes and good
jobs
and I'm just kind of laughing because
those are my
buddies well and odly enough I'm a
firefighter EMT and so it's kind of on
the other side of the
map my gosh okay so you're a guy who is
not willing who is willing to go in and
do dangerous things on behalf of his
community you like art you also like
Fitness M where is this story coming
from that you're
boring that you need to lead with your
car in square footage of your
home lead with
artist lead with I'm obsessed with
landscape photography and paintings oh
and by the way if you're ever having um
congestive heart failure I can help oh
and by the way let's go rock
climbing good gosh dude the line of
people who are going to want to date you
is going to be down the road here's the
scary thing I think you need to
metabolize okay okay if you find an
amazing woman
to date you it will not heal
you m that hole you feel will not come
from the
outside okay you know what I'm saying
yes
absolutely Bro you've got a lot to
offer beyond your car and job
and home
mhm do you believe
me yeah I I believe you I believe you I
trust you con conceptually Yeah well
yeah it's I think part partly I I felt
like this because it's almost in some
ways it's as I became more successful on
that paper in a way like some of the
relationships maybe this like validates
what you're saying of like I was kind of
attracting the wrong kind of people
because was I was looking better on
paper in some ways and being
uh higher value in a way and then it
just but I didn't have the confidence
still and so it attracted like kind of
the the per people that can kind of
latch on to that and kind of just
consume consume is the great word
they're vampires they want the external
metrics yeah because for some reason
they believe they'll be safer if the
person they're with has a car and job X
and whatever and there's some some truth
to that right I mean if you have those
things you're always going to eat right
you're always going to have air
conditioning and that roof over your
head those are important things
yes I think I've talked about this on
the show but there was a really
important moment this last year when my
wife and I had a great interaction um it
wasn't great at the time but it's become
one of the most important ones of our
marriage and of my whole
life when she was like
Hey like how much I love you for how
much money you make that's
full go chase these certificates and
these Awards and these bestseller go do
all that you
want but I love you as much as I'm going
to love
you and she's like I don't I don't I
don't care if we don't get another
plaque on the wall down in the basement
that says that X number of people bought
your book she goes I love
you yeah and dude that was hard for me
to
reconcile but it came down to I didn't
so much like me that
much and sometimes some small steps
sorry go ahead well sometimes that's
getting separate from the things that
make us come alive when's the last time
you painted
something uh actually yeah was before
the relationship there you go yeah my
about a year
I want you to spend some time over the
next two to three weeks painting
Something
Beautiful okay I can do
that I want you to spend some time over
the next two or three weeks hanging out
with a couple of just dude
buddies with no no intent to go get
girls y'all just go hang
out go golfing go fishing go to a game
go do
something
okay but tell jokes
talk about music talk about art talk
about rock climbing and the weirdos in
the rock climbing
Community you see what I'm saying I want
you to Circle back to
humanity because what's going to happen
is you're going to find somebody that
falls in love with who Nick actually is
and the
stability that you're anchored into
you're a hard worker you got a good job
you got a house that's going to be bonus
that's going to be on top
of her actually loving the real guy not
just the so the dog and pony show
because jobs are going to come and
go yeah cars come and
go but Nick the guy who loves art the
guy who works really hard the guy who
wants to be a good Steward of his body
the guy who loves people so much that it
got himself in trouble with this last
girlfriend that guy's etching Stone
that's who you are and that guy's worth
falling in love
with does that make sense absolutely
thank you yes I want you to you don't
have to send me the original but I want
you to take a picture of your landscape
and I I want you to send it to me direct
message or email it to the show and um
we'll put it up on the screen uh and let
everybody see
it I'll give you a homework assignment
you got a couple of weeks I want to see
that I want to see that that beautiful
painting I want you to get back in touch
with being still and seeing something
beautiful and creating something
beautiful and reconnecting with Nick cuz
Nick's worth more than the car he drives
and the house he lives in and the job he
has those things are all important don't
get me wrong that's not
Nick Nick's bigger than
that